this video was voted for by patrons of
questions for science hello okay baby
are you gonna you stay from the butcher
shop I'm taking a kidney to a hospital
right now I'm really busy but I'm hungry
I'm just a gem today okay well I'll do
it I'm done you literally prize baby
this is a matter of life and death I
will do it later okay yeah but you
literally promise are you gonna have it
by a certain time in like Oh oh my gosh
okay listen I'll go to the butcher shop
I'll get this steak and I'll drop it off
in ten minutes okay okay thank you
everybody their baby put the stink-eye
nice for you hey anytime hey Doc sorry
I'm late I'll be at the hospital in five
or ten minutes cytoskeletal tied up
[Applause]
in 2018 there was over 36,000 organ
transplants performed in the US however
there's over 100,000 patients on the
waiting list and every day 18 people die
waiting for a new organ
because organs are in such high demand
and transplantation is a delicate
process getting the organ from the donor
to the recipients in a timely manner is
everything the organs life begins
counting down once blood flow and oxygen
stops going to the organ from here a
list of events take place each
increasing the probability of organ
damage the first event is hypoxia or the
lack of sufficient oxygen in tissue
cells require oxygen in order to make
ATP to make energy which powers our men
about processes to stay alive with no
oxygen available cells must switch from
aerobic metabolism to anaerobic
metabolism which makes ATP without using
oxygen anaerobic metabolism keeps the
cells functioning for an extended period
of time but does have a major setback
it makes lactic acid as a byproduct if
there's enough lactic acid in the tissue
it can make it acidic on the other hand
if the organ were in the body this
wouldn't be a problem
lactic acid in the body is recycled in
the liver into pyruvate by oxidation no
harm no foul also the individual
eventually increases their own oxygen
intake switching back to aerobic
metabolism but in this case the organ is
outside the body in a bag in a box with
no means to recycle the lactic acid or
supply oxygen the tissue becomes
dangerously acidic this is why organs
are put on ice when they're transported
the ice puts the organ into a
hypothermic state between four and eight
degrees Celsius this Kluwer temperature
makes the cells less active therefore
requiring less ATP which means less
lactic acid in transport protocols
organs are first flushed with their
preservation solution that fills the
blood vessels of the organ this
preservation solution contains amino
acids and salts to keep the organ stable
for a longer period of time the organ is
then placed in a plastic bag containing
more solution this organ bag is then put
into a second bag filled with saline
solution and these two bags are placed
into a third bag filled with ice and
more
Dalene you might think well why not just
freeze the organ that way he'll be
preserved even longer
not exactly temperatures below two
degrees Celsius have been shown to cause
frostbite damage in protein denaturation
and cells making the organ useless
the second thing to worry about is as
Moses since the organ is in a
hypothermic state the cells are less
active as a result the sodium potassium
pumps in the cell membrane are also less
active this poses a major problem
because sodium that's typically pumped
out of the cell during normal
functioning remains inside for a longer
period of time
this higher concentration of sodium
draws water into the cell due to osmosis
osmosis is the movement of fluid from an
area of low solute concentration to an
area of high solute concentration
basically there's more sodium in here
than here so the water flows into the
cell where there's more sodium this
makes the cell hypotonic causing it to
swell if enough water gets into the cell
it can burst causing damage to the organ
finally even though the organ is in a
hypothermic State it's using less energy
and is in a preservative solution the
lack of oxygen will eventually cause
organ death so the best precaution to
keeping an organ safe is short transit
time between the donor and the recipient
in fact if you're on vacation you'd
better help your flight is carrying a
donated organ flights that are given to
organs for transport are immediately
bumped to priority ultimately the amount
of time an organ can last outside the
body comes down to which organ is being
transplanted since organs have different
types of tissue and roles in the body
they also have different tolerances to
lack of oxygen the most tolerant organ
in low oxygen environments is by far the
kidney it's been shown to last up to 36
hours outside the body in ideal
conditions the kidney is able to
withstand this abuse because it's
largely made up of very small tubes
called nephrons that filter out waste
from the blood interestingly when
there's no blood flowing through the
nephron the concentration gradient
around these vessels are largely
undisturbed acting as its own
preservative solution because these
conditions are virtually the same the
kidney can last much longer also
historically the kidney is the most
commonly transplant
in Oregon so it's had the most
preservation research done on it next
the pancreas has a max life of about 15
hours outside the body the liver is
tolerant up to 12 hours
however because liver cells contain a
large supply of glycogen labor tissue
has a high risk of becoming overly
acidic from lattic acid production when
the organ switches to anaerobic
metabolism for safety reasons 8 hours is
strongly recommended finally the most
sensitive organs when outside the body
are the heart and lungs because they
have many intricate vessels that can be
damaged in a short period of time
they're very intolerant to low oxygen
conditions both the heart and lungs can
withstand no more than 4 hours outside
the body
here's the kitchen thanks wait a second
this isn't a kidney huh this is a Chop
House sirloin cut in the shape of a
kidney oh I can't believe it
[Music]
what's the patient's blood type a B
negative I may be negative take my
kidney
who are you well I'm you how are you me
if I'm laying here and I give you my
kidney well to be honest you've been
working on this video for two weeks
non-stop and you're exhausted so we go
I fell asleep eating kidney beans he
caught us a plot twist
this isn't a kidney this is a Chop House
sirloin cut in the shape of a kidney
you